aloha your comment vous allez regarder
ce que j'ai ici j'ai reçu un nouveau
gros colis de la part de google un
nouveau brocoli c'est déjà commencé un
peu à regarder vous avoue que c'est
curieux je voulais savoir ce qu'il y
avait dedans puisque je vais vous en
parler aujourd'hui
alors on va faire ça comme ça dansait
avec ça on va regarder directement ce
cas là dedans et vous allez voir truc
est assez rigolo ce sont des surprises
pour cette fin d'année
si vous le savez je voulais déjà dit je
suis en bas ça vient google nest depuis
peu de temps donc ça veut dire que c'est
des trucs très cool à vous montrer j'en
ai de tous les côtés donc là google la
fin joli petit colis avec deux produits
super sympa découvrir regardez là je
vais l'ouvrir et vous montrer
directement
j'aime bien toujours les petits villages
qui a dedans le facilitateur de bill
joie de chine google parce qu'ils m'ont
bien petit moi j'aime bien timo on
retrouve bien pour l'univers google
voyait que les couleurs les symboles les
motifs
nous sommes ravis de vous présenter
toutes dernières nouveautés google nous
avons pour mission proposer des produits
google toujours plus utile ça tout ça
tout ça tout ça ok ça c'est cool
découvrez votre nouveau google chrome
castet votre mine est au max alors moi
je connais déjà ses produits le nest max
j'en ai déjà la maison j'utilise depuis
tellement longtemps et le chrome caste
je connais c'est pour venir castet votre
contenu en garde et hop là je vous ouvre
sa regardez-moi ça comme c'est mignon
n'est-on max chrome castres on est
vraiment dans l'univers du
divertissement ici on voit que le chrome
casque google tv
si vous tentez d'accéder à tous vos
contenus google sans n'importe quelle
télé ça c'est très très cool et le nez
stone max ça s'est un peu plus gros un
peu plus lourd n'est-on mac c'est
vraiment super génial parce qu'en fait
le dos comme max c'est votre assistant
pour la maison vous venez commander
votre à google à 6 ans à la voix est
bien là en plus de l'avoir vous avez un
écran vous avez en plus une caméra sur
le dessus pour faire de la visio pour la
sécurité sont vraiment deux accessoires
supra coule dans l'univers du
divertissement c'est vraiment cette idée
là vous pouvez donc venir ici piloter
très facilement tout votre contenu avec
votre voix ces salles from caste c'est
ici un petit accessoire que vous venez
connecter directement en hdmi sur votre
télévision
et ça me permet de cast est tous très
facilement et en plus avec vous avez une
télécommande inclus parce que oui on
peut piloter avec la voix mais c'est
quand même des fois bien d'avoir un
petit appareil physique sous la main ici
vous naviguez très facilement vous
tout chute hub une touche netflix vous
branchez votre chrome cast avec la ligne
que vous avez ici et ici en plus j'ai
des piles pour venir mettre sur ma
télécommande le nez stollmack c'est une
autre paire de manches la boîte est tout
de suite un pape une grosse là vous avez
un grand écran sur lequel va s'afficher
tout votre contenu ça d'écrans tactiles
votre caméra qui est là vous avez deux
micros en façade
ici au dos vous avez un bouton pour
venir activer désactiver la caméra vous
avez le bouton de volume pour monter le
son et des selles sont votre lim qui se
situe juste là pour tout le côté
divertissement c'est génial parce que
vous allez pouvoir regarder
netflix regarder des séries regarder
youtube lorsque vous je sais pas à laver
la vaisselle lorsque vous coupez des
carottes attention à pas vous coûter un
bout de doigt
si google combien de temps pour faire
cuire des pommes de terre combien de
temps pour un oeuf cocotte enfin la
faisait toutes ces questions lui va
venir vous répondre directement donc
vous avez les mains sales des mains dans
le pétrin et lui fait le taf pour vous
vous pouvez également demander de lance
un minuteur ok google lance un minuteur
sur trente secondes une minute deux
minutes en fonction de vos besoins
tout ce que vous pouvez faire avec votre
assistant google vous pourrez faire ici
en plus avec un écran tactile donc là
c'est super bien vous pouvez en plus
utilisés
je vais vous montrer dans quelques
instants pour passer des coups de fil
avec des amis grâce à google duo vous
pouvez piloter toute maison connectée
piloter vos lumières mais le mieux c'est
encore de vous montrer directement je
vous emmène à la maison je vous montre
comment je l'utilisent
là par exemple si vous regardez en train
de faire un duo avec le studio ça c'est
moi là tout temps au petit qui suis en
train de filmer et là c'est le studio
dont vous pourriez faire un duo très
facilement avec le studio si vous le
voulez si vous avez des contacts
sinon vous pouvez le faire avec votre
papa votre maman vos amis surtout en
période de confinement tout de suite qui
est pas très rigolo
vous pouvez vous connecter très
facilement avec plusieurs personnes en
utilisant google duo que vous
téléchargez sur n'importe quel appareil
et vous avez intégré directement ici
nous voici donc à la maison avec le
google n'est stop max je vous montre
comment ça marche première chose il fait
quatre photos il vous indique l'heure
est la météo
vous pouvez faire défiler vos photos
facilement à droite à gauche vous pouvez
ensuite glissé comme ça ici pour accéder
à toutes vos informations
ici j'ai un tableau de bord dans lequel
je vois ma météo du mot
en mai je vois également les lumières
qui sont connectés dans ma maison j'ai
le contrôle de mes lumières j'ai des
routines que je peut programmer mes
différentes pièces mais caméra pour la
surveillance et mes enceintes
voyez ici je vois toutes les lumières de
la maison je peut éteindre toutes les
lumières les allumés et ensuite j'ai
pièce par pièce très facilement vu
qu'ici j'ai des ampoules connectés dans
toute la maison voit notamment mes
différentes pièces de la maison avec les
différents objets qui sont présentes
dans j'ai ensuite accès à tous les
contenus multimédias qui va venir me
proposait notamment sur youtube du crew
d'une cuisinette stats j'ai ensuite mon
contenu spotify que je me retrouverais
ici par exemple si je veux mettre un une
vidéo de cuisine et de stats et bien
voyez j'ai qu'à appuyer dessus et lui
vient me lancer directement sur youtube
vous avez ensuite les fonctions comme
unité pour venir communiqué alors
annoncer ça c'est assez marrant parce
que ça sert d'interface dans toute la
maison je passais un appel téléphonique
à partir d'ici passent un appel vidéo
avec duo ou alors appeler une autre
pièce et ensuite j'ai une fonction
découvrir pour découvrir plein de choses
que je peux faire ici lancé un des
jeunes est au max c'est bien plus que du
divertissement il viendra vraiment vous
rendre service pour piloter toute votre
maison connectée les connecter j'ai
mangé ce rapport hdmi d'un côté sur
l'alimentation
c'est très simple la configuration est
extrêmement simple sur vos smartphones
une foule d'applications google chrome
qui est vraiment le centre la
collectivité de tous vos appareils non
violent vous riez déjà quant aux on a
plusieurs catégories recherché pour vous
films séries et met en application il ya
franchement ce qu'il faut que ce soit du
disney + youtube et il ya également des
jeux de quoi venir à vous amuser on est
vraiment dans l'univers du
divertissement ici je peux ensuite
cliquer sur mon petit bouton home pour
arriver à mon menu principal donc là je
reviens au menu principal pour vous je
veux un peu trop même recommandé un film
sur prat une vidéo je vais avoir c'est
quoi ce après une vidéo également gêné
de flex que tu prennes vidéo mais canal
france tv molotov disney et youtube
musique et vous avez même un bouton pour
venir parler à google directement au
quai google quel temps fait-il à paris
aujourd'hui selon les prévisions
aujourd'hui
des averses avec si vous n'avez pas une
smart tv et bien vous brancher sur le
port hdmi de votre télé et vous attendez
beaucoup plus marque beaucoup plus
intelligente vous avez en plus des
petits boutons de volume ici qui vous
permettent de commander le son de votre
télé en gros cette télécommande là elle
va venir remplacer celle de votre
téléviseur c'est extrêmement pratique à
la maison j'étais j'ai une télé avec
chrome qu'à s'intégrer donc c'est vrai
que j'utilise pas en physique mais si
vous avez une télé où vous n'avez pas de
chrome qu'à s'intégrer et bien vous
pouvez venir lâche tes amis les liens en
bas dans la description c'est très
pratique pour mir castet du contenu de
n'importe quel appareil directement sur
votre téléviseur et pour avoir un google
tv
par contre l'appareil que j'utilise au
quotidien à la maison c'est celui là le
matin par exemple ça nous à ce qui est
tout bête
il reconnaît votre visage que vous avez
au préalable enregistrez vous dit
bonjour bonjour aurélien en ce qui me
concerne si vous appelez aurélien il
vous dira bonjour au régal mais si vous
appelez monique il vous dira bonjour
monique les compris l'histoire
d'ailleurs bonjour à toi monique des
kilos a reconnu votre visage il vous
dira ensuite combien de temps il vous
faut pour aller au travail ils vous
affichera la météo fait c'est vraiment
extrêmement pratique il vous fait
revivre tous vos souvenirs au travers de
vos photos vous le piloter à la voix
c'est marrant et ça c'est vraiment un
accessoire que j'adore je vais découvert
il ya à un an et demi ça doit faire un
peu plus d'un an gelé à la maison et
c'est vraiment un produit que j'adore et
qui vraiment au centre de ma maison
voilà pour ces deux produits si les
google moi je trouve super cool a vous
de me dire nous ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire quel est le produit
que vous préférez est-ce que c'est
plutôt pour n'ira castet sur votre télé
est ce que c'est votre nez stade max ici
on est quoi faire pour le divertissement
pour la maison connectée pour se
simplifier la vie et apporter toujours
plus de services à sa maison dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous utilisez un
de ces deux produits et surtout est-ce
que vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
sur ce je vous envoie roux beaucoup
d'amour double bisous prenez soin de
vous et surtout a très vite tintin
[Musique]